[Music]
I'm Andy signor director of man-at-arms
to show for break media we put it on the
ami channel on each week we found this
amazing blacksmith I am now proud to
call him my blacksmith Tony swattin and
each week he builds a weapon from
scratch based off pop culture I have an
example right here this is the Keyblade
from Kingdom Hearts which is quite heavy
and quite dangerous so the show came
about for us wanting to do a sort of
Dooley sort of action II sort of show
and like the tools is what we sort of
where it came from and so I had seen
some clips online of blacksmiths doing
stuff and the views were a huge view is
that people just hammering like daggers
and stuff and I thought this is cool why
isn't someone making like you know the
he-man sword and like doing actual
weapons I called several blacksmiths
around they there are not apparently as
many blacksmiths as you'd think every
other blacks when they talk to you told
me to talk to Tony and so then once I
talked to Tony he's like yeah talk to
any of the blacksmith you want you're
gonna call me back because I'm the only
guy who can do this and it turned out he
was it was true so it was just a Google
search of finding blacksmith in that
area and then referrals to Tony and Tony
ended up being sort of the dream come
true of making everything we wanted he
was able to do it any new media
rockstars so Gimli Zak's here just
Fitness all up I was always interested
in this kind of stuff we couldn't afford
it so I started my clown and now I have
all of us all those trolls are saying
he's not real sorts and eat it right
Tony this is real
would do some serious damage cut my nose
off right here this is 43 stitches just
hang in there this is a cut from
stabbing a knife to sheathing it into my
arm
this is just speckled burns from this
week's built for you guys the Keyblade
you'll see the flash fires shooting out
of that made a flamethrower
very very cool except it's my arm things
with with the show is I'm not that
familiar with the pop culture I don't
watch television
I'm had a TV hooked up since 1997 I
don't play video games I've made the bat
left type weapons before for Star Trek
but I haven't made them you know to this
realism you know it's really out of
aluminum this thing was pretty
redonkulous
you know just trying to interpret a
fifth sword and yeah I won't say this is
when I challenge Tony on as like Tony we
really need to do this minecraft sort
and Tony what was your response to that
oh yeah sure no problem
I don't wanna you can't make me this is
what this is one piece we did push a
little bit that he made because and the
reason I pushed because I knew he was
gonna make something amazing and he
figured out he always does this is one
of the coolest things I think we've made
you think right this is pretty cool it's
pretty cool still weird but like Jaime
Lannister sword
Ninja Turtles sighs for Raphael was
great yeah because I'm more familiar
with the traditional weapons as opposed
to video games and stuff that I'm
completely oblivious to the Kingdom
Hearts sword I see these people at cons
walking around and crazy wigs and this
gigantic tin foil wrapped piece of
toilet paper tube or carpet tube or
something and I'm like you know what is
this and so now I had to make it you
know but it took out the door pretty
good everything I make for man-at-arms
is my fan base interpretation of other
people's properties if people want to
buy a piece that they've seen on the
show if they can get me written
permission from Cartoon Network or
marble or Disney or Warner Brothers then
I will talk price with them but
otherwise you're welcome to come to my
showroom in Burbank California we're
open on Saturdays you can see some of
the pieces on my website WWN comm but
they are not for sale you know I do take
private Commission's but right now about
two to three years out and pieces
started about two to five thousand
dollars in 2015 if you place your order
now and I'm interested in taking
Commission I may be able to deliver
something to you we just updated my
website because it was exploding it's
now like a terabyte of bandwidth and
when this show comes out we'll probably
have to bump it's more seasoned too
amped up a lot we actually took a lot
more comments from the users like this
season to is all requests from the users
and so it was a hybrid of figuring out
which ones can we do because we shoot we
shoot the show on a block of six just so
it's easier for Tony to get these done
so we took six of the most Amann
comments this season we have the Kingdom
Hearts keyblade we have a Klingon I'm
gonna say it wrong the USA at the BOK
law
you
it's the stuff played with the Klingon
blade from Star Trek okay they've
Captain America shield the minecraft
diamond sword
Gimli Zacks from lore the Rings the
Buster Sword from Final Fantasy which
was a huge one that was a huge literally
a six-foot blade that he's gonna be
crushing some wooden tables with in
season two we really went bigger to like
we wanted more action we want bigger
weapons we wanted stuff that people
asked for my man arms you take the
production really seriously like we
would shoot it very slickly our DP
matter one is fantastic he's in here all
week following Tony like with the
amazing camera package shooting it just
so professionally slick that you it it
would seem like the show would be boring
week after week watching these builds
but it's not like we document it's so
cool like you just watch every piece of
every weapon that we feel like this show
I feel like the shows really giving you
a really cool sort of Discovery Channel
vibe but you're getting really this sort
of very like niche sort of objects that
you wouldn't normally get to see
anywhere else we sort of do what we want
because we sort of wait for people to
tell us that we can't do it just because
we don't want to disappoint the fans the
sort of the argument is this these are
Tony's interpretations of the weapons so
I feel like we get around it that way
but we try not to say can't tony
specifically like when i give him a
sword can you make the buster sword
which is a gigantic sword yeah of course
he's like well if you need me to make
i'm gonna make the poster sword so we
definitely tried us to make no rules
like make the biggest coolest things we
can my favorite weapon so far is
probably been the adventuretime fins
golden blade really turned golden sword
turned out really cool this season so
far the Minecraft sword is pretty
awesome I have to say that might that
might surpass it there's a lot of damage
if you take a look there's a lot of
carnage that we have to be very careful
of we take the show extremely seriously
we have you know a medics on set we have
a stunt team who goes through and safety
you know make sure we have Freddy pad
and walls because it is web that does
that you that's an expense that most web
shows probably all have to deal with is
the safety aspect but it adds a lot of
our costs cuz we have to be sure that no
one's walking around on the broken glass
without it being sweeps away so safety
is super important no one's gotten hurt
thank God
and so so far no problems but it's
definitely sort of a fun sense because
it is there's always a little you never
know on season 1 some of the swords
broke which we didn't want to show right
away just because we had to build it so
fast and so see and we didn't want to
show that piece but and season 2 the
reason they did is cause Tony had to
build them so fast so that was a more
dangerous safety thing that we learned
we have to be even be careful and season
2 he's now tempered them to their death
so like you could literally drive
anything on these it just takes twice as
long to build them but we made sure this
around that doesn't even happen so all
these weapons are just completely sturdy
working weapons this is our set medic
George
have we had any trouble oh really yes
there you go oh yeah it's pretty good -
we got political answer no really and
real dangers this is Brian
he's Tony's go-to what's your what's
your title uh grunting grunt link
Brian's a huge resource and our stunts
and our and he knows the pop culture
stuff way better than Tony and you also
know the cool stuff that Tony's built
can you show us some of the fun stuff
yeah first off pirates the Caribbean
this is Johnny Depp's sword right now
this is me touching Johnny Depp's tip
that just happened he's in Soul Calibur
little soul edge action going on there
Tony's first big gig was making the hook
for a hook what a lot of people don't
know is he actually made a bunch Oaks
because they didn't know what they
wanted
Donna hooks you've made a little baby
hook for the little teddy bear in this
case over here we got we got Zorro
we got Sucker Punch we have sweet pea
spelled Hren from Hellboy we have the
kernels the curtilage blades
we have daggers from alias we have Last
Samurai this is actually the blade we
remade for I believe it was
Criminal Minds we make stunts versions
out of aircraft aluminum we make the
real thing so here's the real thing we
made and then they went out and they
made a rubber version so as you can see
I was kind of looks better so here we do
the real thing we don't make things that
are
Robert it's all bye it's all by hand
there's nothing automated the spear of
destiny from Constantine yes most people
did think it was it would be bigger you
know camera add six inches
these are katy perry's scale male arms
be jealous down here we see some cans of
spam we did not actually make that spam
that spam was actually a gift from the
whole cast of spam a lot cuz we actually
made a big goblet i believe a big goblet
and then to curry sword which he really
liked and he did terrible things to it i
hear but it's to curry so it's totally
okay I got Deadliest Warrior and I can
show you Katy Perry's boobs let's do it
but I made this for season 1 episode 1 a
Deadliest Warrior on Spike channel Chuck
Liddell cut a cow in half with this not
even kidding look it up a cow in half
with this moving along over here we got
a steampunk arm and some goggles that
was used by panic at the disco I believe
in the ballad of Mona Lisa we have
Prince Caspian sword one of the things
were actually doing in our show
currently is where are you making an axe
at a Damascus it's a pattern weld where
we actually have multiple layers the one
we're currently doing has 143 I believe
layers of individual sheets of metal
that Tony then Forge welds together Tony
has made multiple wonder woman costumes
worn by men and women alike as well as
an entire Xena outfit for Rainn Wilson
or Dwight Schrute from the office
I believe that's in Bogor people look
that up we also have here just our Katy
Perry's arms this is Katy Perry's
breastplate from the et music video so
to get this Tony it does what he likes
to call a saliva cast he's a little more
detailed a little more painstaking but
you just kind of get that level of
detail and you kind of get to connect
with your Maliki get inside their head
or is this the mold from Rockville booth
this actually is perfectly fit to her
Wow so that's what it would be like to
touch her boob this is this is just our
boobs yeah I mean there's no nipples
it's happening just a yeah just to make
it okay here we go okay yeah but this is
all this is all hammered you know this
is all you know that's how we you get
those to you like wow those look like
hammer strikes that's because they are
there's no way to cheat that what feel
like underneath because her boobs touch
that yeah that's touch that part yes
they did actually my hands touching
where she not I do not believe she could
wear a bra see because of the D comes
from well then by god yeah in the back
we have the breasts of such celebrities
as Britney Spears I think we have Janet
Jackson Queen Latifah that's a lot of
metal
you go girl you go girl Souter I'm right
here originally made for John Cleese
that's right
he's not home right now
yeah I'll just shut up something like
these if you came into our shop we're
open on Saturdays to the public for
knife sharpening as well as rentals and
and purchases and things and I believe
our if you want a stun sword same swords
that you know you see being used in Thor
pirates the Caribbeans like that which
is aircraft aluminum and it's hard to
tell alright which one is which
I don't know Toni's made many iconic
items including the hook from hook in
the blade for blade I'm waiting for a
movie called hammer and then I'm for us
to build the hammer so we can hit then
I've also built the hammer from hammer
or the axe from axe or the mask from
mask
[Music]
[Music]
you